bonjour
votre nom monsieur travelling m'a
demandé de venir vous rejoindre il vous
a rien dit rien du tout facteur né soyez
prudent avec monsieur travelling on ne
sait jamais
quelle surprise alors qu'est ce que
c'est qu'un nouveau gâteau un nouveau
super jouer pas du tout
et monsieur travail n'est pas là je ne
comprends pas il m'a demandé de venir
d'urgence
cerf avec joie de revoir son véritable
nom heureux et particulièrement flatté
de constater vous êtes rendus chacun à
mon avis parce c'est tout à fait normal
de ce tram ligne 1 alors alors j'ai
surpris ça et bien voici je viens
d'avoir une idée géniale qui a germé
dans mon cerveau fertile et enfin
thierry v très
chers amis mais pas sans avoir constaté
comme moi quand cette saison le jardin
et ses alentours sont dans un état
d'abandon
déplore je trouve que vous exagérez un
peu le monsieur travaille le jardin est
très jolie non pas tant qu'il me
faudrait aussi j'ai décidé de vous aider
à le transformer en un lieu enchanteur
qui attirera les touristes du monde
entier
et qui permettra de gagner beaucoup
d'argent
c'est en effet une très belle idée
monsieur train de vie il ya certainement
beaucoup de choses qu'on peut encore
améliorer dans notre jardin après tout
j'aurais peut-être plus de clients pour
mon cas ah oui ça c'est vrai aussi il
faut établir un plan de travail bon
attendez attendez qui veut roux qui veut
se charger d'élaguer les arbres à il me
semble que françois avec son agilité
oui c'est un vrai sage au bonjour merci
semir bon ben c'est entendu je
commencerai dès demain a pas d'accord
d'accord en france bon une fois les
arbres élagués il faudra ramasser les
branches et les mettre en cinq jours sur
sept
[Rires]
mais attendez attendez il reste encore
deux occupations très importante tout
d'abord s'occuper des fleurs les
désherber les enfants c'est pour julie
oui oui j'aimerais beaucoup d'attention
et puis pour terminer s'occuper du gazon
à ça moi je voulais les effets tombeau
ces images je vais vous faire un gazon
il y
soyons au volant et vous qu'en pensez
vous ah c'est vrai et vous
moi moi moi il me reste le plus
difficile le plus fatiguant je dois
m'occuper tous courir d'un endroit à
l'autre surveiller consulter braivois
à ne
jamais jamais personne ne me
comprendront
je suis
cet instrument est peut-être très bien
pour couper les grandes herbes mais
certainement pas pour le petit gazon de
notre jardin
françois bon choix des 100 minutes j'ai
besoin de points et didot casimir
pourquoi tu voulais faucher ma chaise là
qui t'arrive mais il coûte 1 je crois
que ceci n'est pas du tout adapté pour
le petit gazon du jardin où elle est ni
pour nos chaises et casimir pourtant
dingue un gazon se serrent pas d'une
fausse et pas du tout ce qui convient
écoute moi moi je ne connais rien en
jardinage écoute il faudra que tu
l'appelles les enfants et que que tu
nous expliques à quoi servent tous les
outils qui sont dans la karma c'est une
très bonne idée on va même faire un jeu
venez les enfants venaient tous prenez
chacun est l'outil dans la cabane et on
va expliquer à casimir à quoi il sert et
comment il s'appelle bon on va commencer
par l'outil donc se serrent casimir tu
nous a dit que ça s'appelle une focale
signé à quoi ça sert une femme fauchée
je pense à faucher quoi en page sûrement
les grands airs de mais sûrement pas le
petit castor faucher ça veut dire coupez
en fait comme ceci va à peu près parce
que c'est un geste très difficile et si
on ne fait pas bien on attrape très vite
malheureux bon montre nous ton outils de
jardinage toi une bêche et ça sert à
quoi
abéché cittadino
à retourner la terre l'a fait une
démonstration oui en enfance voilà
on retourne la motte de terre ont la
casse et noël coup dessus comme ça et on
continue très bien françoise parce que
ça c'est plutôt c'est un râteau ça sert
à quoi pour égaliser la terre irradiée
oui ça sert à ratisser fait une petite
démonstration
oui on planche et ramasser les feuilles
mortes après ta wii également quasi
également mais il ya il ya un outil de
jardinage qui convient qu'on aime mieux
pour les feuilles mortes monde
montrez nous que c'est est ce que c'est
ça
un sarcloir
et ça sert à quoi
c'est ça dans les allées quand il ya une
mauvaise herbe ont la gratte comme ça
et ça qu'est ce que c'est une fourche
mais à quoi ça sert la fourche
la fois oui comment fait-on hop on le
pique
et on leur tire très bien ces deux jours
là vous faire attention une souche
statique qu'est ce que c'est que cet
engin une tondeuse à gazon et ça sert
à tondre le gazon fait une petite
démonstration
plus comme ça voilà mais aime et sait
pouvoir faire l'outil qu'il m'en faut
deux journées de la pression c'est pour
milan alors avec ça plus de problème je
suis sûr que je vais réussir très bien
formidable mais revoilà bon aussi les
entendre à canal
[Musique]
casimir que fais tu là il est 6 heures
et tu n'as pas encore mangé je suis
épuisée et c'est à cause de ça monsieur
travelling avec ses idées géniales il
m'a obligé à couper toute l'herbe de
lilas et avec une espèce de machine qui
fait bon bon bon bon bon et kim avons
plein de cailloux dans les chevilles à
mon pauvre casimir tout ça c'est parce
que vous n'êtes pas moderne dans cette
île voilà mais c'est faux nous sommes
parfaitement maintenant à marciac
regarde justement cette revue quinzaine
regard de la bien qu'est ce que c'est
que ces drôles d'animaux on lirait des
sortes de robots c'est pour aller sur la
lune
enfin ce n'est pas fait pour aller sur
la lune ce sont tout simplement des
tondeuses à gazon moderne n'a qu'une
voix ce dessin là c'est une tondeuse à
gazon à un moteur comme une automobile
est ce ainsi et électriques comme attend
commun comme comme comme le rasoir
électrique de monsieur travelling voila
voila tu as tout compris comme un rasoir
électrique de monsieur travelling il y a
deux dans une grosse pin ou bien un
grand fils que l'on branche comme ça à
l'électricité mais alors il faut
demander à monsieur travnik de commander
une de ces machines sur le continent
c'est une excellente idée est selon moi
oui mais en attendant il va falloir que
je continue à pousser ma vieille machine
à ma môme bon bon bon bon ben voilà
c'est épuisant à moins que
[Musique]
il a vraiment une bonne idée monsieur
trà vinh pour une fois
françois ne soyez pas mes shows julia
réseau enfin regardez autour de vous
c'est un véritable paradis
il n'ya que casimir qui n'a pas tout à
fait terminée je le vois là bas il avait
été vrai dire une grande surface de
gazon en dhr il l'a fait très
courageusement sa chute
voilà monsieur travelling
band et ses travellings bravo vous avez
une très bonne idée on va regarder pas
de me regardez pas ce qui constitue des
courses ça ne va pas monsieur travelling
vous êtes au rhume et j'avais mal aux
gens non non rien de tout cela il
m'arrive son affreux pour une personne
de ma qualité je n'ai pas pu m'en
séquelles des zones à
s'amuser jamais arrivions j'allais me
désole jamais mais je ne retrouve pas
mon rasoir électrique il a disparu
disparaît
regardez ça me jette au pont du
rasoir électrique
[Musique]